If you want to hear my theory about how Ellie
Creed from Pet Sematary, as well as two other
characters in that story have the same ability
as Danny Torrence from The Shining, then stick
around to the end of this video.
Stephen King’s third full-length novel,
The Shining, is titled after an ability held
by a few of the characters.
The man to introduce us to the ability says
that he and his grandmother call it “the
shine”.
It can be described as a psychic and clairvoyant
power, whose intensity varies from individual
to individual.
Dick Halloran is the name of the head chef
at The Overlook Hotel who teaches Danny everything
he knows about the shine.
He explains that he and his Grandmother used
to have entire conversations without ever
opening their mouths.
“She called it shining.
And for a long time I thought it was just
the two of us that had the shine to us.”
But, it’s not.
Halloran explains that there aren’t a lot
of people who shine, but he has run across
maybe 50 or 60 who have a little bit of shine
to them.
So what does shining actually consist of,
and why do I think that Ellie, from Pet Sematary
has the shine?
As Dick mentioned, those who shine are capable
of telepathic communication.
Danny is also able to hear the thoughts of
those who don’t shine, like how he hears
Mrs. Brant’s thoughts about the hotel’s
valet, Mike.
Now I’m not going to say what those thoughts
consisted of… but….
When Halloran asks Danny if he listens to
his parents’ thoughts, he says he tries
not to invade their privacy, but he can’t
help picking up on their feelings or emotions.
There is evidence of Ellie reading her father’s
mind, or at the very least picking up on his
feelings in Pet Sematary.
The family goes to visit Ellie’s Grandma
and Grandpa on her mother’s side, but Louis
doesn’t go with.
Louis strongly dislikes his father-in-law
because he tried to bribe Louis out of marrying
Rachel, making him quite possibly the champion
of stereotypical in-law characters in fiction.
Ellie somehow seems to know the real reason,
and asks her father if he he’s pissed off
at Grandpa, to which Louis wonders how she
possibly could have known that.
Halloran also warns Danny about some bad dreams
that he’s had at the Overlook.
He tells him, “People who shine can sometimes
see things that are gonna happen, and I think
sometimes they can see things that did happen.”
When Ellie is away at her grandparents’
house, she has a dream of her cat, Church,
dying the night that Church is run over by
a truck and buried in the Mic Mac burial ground.
"I dreamed he got hit by a car and you and
Mr Crandall buried him in the Pet Sematary.”
“That was a silly dream, wasn’t it?”
But it wasn’t too silly of a dream, and
Ellie continues to have dreams about past
and future events.
But if you don’t want to get the ending
of Pet Sematary spoiled for you, I would not
watch any more of this video, why don’t
you check this one out instead?
Those of you who have read the book may remember,
that Ellie’s next dream involves Louis being
dead, a prediction of the end of Pet Sematary.
And when Ellie and Rachel are about to leave
on the plane, Ellie begs her father to let
them stay, or for him to come with, and I
think this is because she senses her father’s
life will be in danger.
She also expresses more of her fears to Louis
at the airport.
“Daddy, I dreamed we were at Gage’s funeral
and the funeral man opened his coffin and
it was empty.
Then I dreamed I was home and I looked at
Gage’s crib and that was empty too.
But there was dirt in it.”
This is just before Louis goes to dig up Gage
and try to revive him in the Mic Mac burial
ground.
The first dream represents the fact that Louis
will empty Gage’s coffin in Pleasantview
Cemetery; and the second one is a reminder
of when the ghost of Victor Pascow tried to
warn Louis in the night not to go on to the
cursed burial ground, and Louis wakes up with
the dirt of the Pet Sematary path on his feet
in bed the next morning.
Just before boarding the plane, Ellie begs
one last time.
Listen to this portion.
Ellie gazed at him solemnly with her sybil’s
eyes.
“I don’t want to go,” she said again,
but so low that only Louis could really hear
over the shuffle and murmur of the boarding
passengers.
“I don’t want Mommy to go either.”
“Ellie, come on,” Louis said.
“You’ll be fine.”
“I’ll be fine,’ she said, ‘but what
about you?
Daddy, what about you?”
I find it very interesting that King uses
describes Ellie’s gaze as having come through
sybil’s eyes, a word derived from the Greek
word “sibulla” which described a woman
who utters the oracles and prophecies of a
god.
Shortly after, Ellie has another vision on
the plane, where she describes Gage coming
alive again and weilding a knife.
What happens next is interesting if you think
about another aspect of the shine that Dick
Halloran describes to Danny.
He asks Danny to contact him if there is any
trouble at the Overlook, that he might even
hear his call way down in Florida.
Danny later does use this to call for help
when all other lines of communication have
been cut, sending Halloran on his way to try
to rescue the Torrance family.
Personally, I probably would have the just
let the little **** die, I mean it’s so
much colder in Colorado than it is in Florida,
why would you leave?
Something similar happens in Pet Sematary,
however, instead of the child calling out
for help, it is the ghost of Victor Pascow
who contacts Ellie in her dream and takes
her to the Pet Sematary in an attempt to try
to get her to tell Rachel what she had seen.
It’s possible that this isn’t an example
of a “long distance call” using the Shining
though, because maybe Pascow is just able
to travel anywhere because he’s a ghost.
This does send Rachel on her way to try to
put a stop to Louis’s actions.
However, it seems unlikely that she would
randomly take the word of a 6 year old based
on a bad dream she had.
This is why I think that Rachel has a little
bit of a shine to her as well; in fact, when
Halloran did mention that he thinks all mothers
shine a little, at least until their kids
grow up enough to watch out for themselves.
This would also explain why Pascow is able
help Rachel throughout the latter part of
the story.
But there’s one more character that I think
has a tiny bit of shine as well.
When Rachel is on her way back from Chicago,
she phones Jud Crandall to see if he knows
why Louis isn’t home.
When speaking to her, he mentions that she
sounds closer, and although she did sound
closer somehow, he hears the sound of the
wind on the line, and it reminds him of the
sound of dead voices sighing in chorus.
I don’t think Jud or Rachel realize they
have the shine, but if he does have some faint
sign of it, it would explain how he senses
that Louis was getting ideas about burying
Gage in the Mic Mac grounds.
“You’re thinking of puttin’ him up there.
Don’t deny the thought hadn’t crossed
your mind Louis.”
There is one more major aspect of the shine
though, that leads me to believe that Ellie
has pretty strong case of it.
When Halloran is trying to gauge how strong
Danny’s shine is, he asks him to blast a
thought as hard as he can.
Danny is much more powerful than anticipated
though.
Halloran flies back in his seat and his injured
by the force of Danny’s shine, which he
compares to a Nolan Ryan fastball.
Ellie may be channeling a little Fergie Jenkins
herself, because after Rachel leaves to go
back to Ludlow, her father phones Louis about
a dream Ellie had, that is so powerful they
end up taking her to the hospital.
Let me know in the comments if you can come
up with any other Stephen King characters
who have the shine, and watch this video if
you want to hear some of the things you might
have missed in Stephen King’s IT.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications, and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.